well first of all congratulations i feel
like everywhere i look it is you four
thank you
let's get right into your new single
life's too short if there ever was a
time that we needed a song an anthem
about spreading love it is
right now what do you want fans to know
about this song we want our fans to know
that it really does truly come from our
hearts that we really believe that life
is too short for any negativity and that
we should all be using our time to
spread positivity and spread
[Music]
love there a moment that you knew you
had to put this song out because we
needed it
too
the choreography is
amazing how much fun did you have on set
that day
oh
now speaking of music videos i have to
congratulate you on the music video for
savage just hit 200 million views
what was your reaction when
you saw that number
we've always felt so grateful for our
fans but when there's a new record new
thing
we get you know that feeling again and
again and again and we can't you know
express how much we are grateful for our
fans and all of us actually really liked
savage and we put a lot of effort into
it and to see it doing well it really
made us proud and super happy oh my gosh
don't you know i'm a savage i'm a killer
we holla dude
[Music]
the ep made history as the highest entry
for a k-pop girl group's debut on the
billboard 200 which is amazing how do
you celebrate those
what we call wins well
you know
things like this don't just happen with
you know just us working hard it comes
with everyone else and the effort that
goes into it
with the people around us and i think to
celebrate
making history
we definitely try our best to show our
gratitude for the people around us
[Music]
will you tour this album
i don't think we have a tour set yet but
we'll definitely be showcasing it in
korea first and then we'll be going to
japan and doing our japanese japan
showcase
and then i think we'll start preparing
for
some new stuff
that's also code for secrets we can't
tell them
now i have to congratulate you too on
making your late night debut here in the
u.s on jimmy kimmel
i loved the photo with paris hilton
an american icon
[Music]
well next up you guys are going to hit
good morning america's summer concert
series which again congratulations
thank you
from coast to coast
what can you tease about that
performance
are you nervous at all the first time to
perform girls um
being that our first performance of
girls will be at this huge concert and
it's it'll be like the day of um release
so you know our fans won't know exactly
our whole choreography yet so it's a
little nerve-wracking but it's a little
more exciting i think we're super
pumped to be able to show you know our
full choreography to our fans do you
have a dream collaboration that you
would like to do we all really love the
weekend's music and
we thought that his style and our style
of music would make a really interesting
blend and it would be great if one day
we could
collab together have you met him yet or
no no we haven't yet okay well i'm big
on manifesting so we're gonna make it
happen we're gonna make
[Laughter]
manifest thank you all so so so much i'm
so happy to see all of the success and i
know so much more is going to come like
i said at the beginning everywhere i
look turn on the every it's you guys
congratulations
thank you